recently there's been a lot of talk
about measles what does measles actually
do and should you vaccinate against it
or is this just hysteria measles is a
virus a hull of proteins RNA plus some
more proteins for reproduction it cannot
reproduce by itself it needs a host cell
to do so to understand measles we have
to understand the immune system you
might already have seen the visual
system we developed to help here now
let's focus on the parts of the immune
system relevant to measles the measles
virus enters humans through the nose
mouth or eyes the measles infection
starts in the lungs measles is
especially good at infecting the body's
first line of defense metro phages
powerful guard cells that protect the
lungs from intruders they enter a cell
and take it over the virus reprograms
the cell and transforms it into a
dangerous virus production center once a
cell there's filled with viruses they
leave the crippled cell and begin the
cycle over again
but the immune system has powerful
weapons against virus infections natural
killer cells these cells basically
patrol the body and check other cells
for infections if they find an infected
cell they order it to commit suicide
this is so effective that for the first
10 days or so you will not even notice
that you're infected with measles and
now the reason why measles is so
powerful after a period of fighting and
dying macrophages alert the brain of the
immune system the dendritic cells the
job of the dendritic cells is to collect
samples of intruders travel to the lymph
nodes and then activate the heavy
weapons that are
keep the infection very fast in a team
effort but the measles virus uses a
dreadful tactic it infects the dendritic
cells and uses them as a Trojan horse to
enter deeper into the body the infected
cells travel to the next lymph node to
alert other immune cells once it arrives
the measles virus spreads around the
Virgin T and B cells and infects them it
attacks the very system that evolved to
fight it now things happen very fast the
lymph system spreads the virus
everywhere and it enters the bloodstream
infecting cells while traveling measles
infects organs like the spleen the liver
the intestines and most importantly the
lungs the symptoms range from a very
high fever headache sickness bronchitis
and of course a rash in the lungs the
immune system was doing pretty ok but
now millions of viruses attack a second
time and killed countless cells wiping
out the defense systems in this phase
you start coughing out millions of
measles viruses measles is so contagious
at this stage that if you meet someone
who isn't vaccinated there's about a 90%
chance you'll infect them without the
protective army in the lungs other
bacteria or viruses that would usually
not stand a chance can now enter the
lungs and develop into harmful parallel
infections that can cause pneumonia
the most common way to die from measles
your body's immune system is now
seriously wounded various protective
systems are hurt and disrupted the virus
spreads everywhere in affecting the skin
all over the body
the typical measles rash now becomes
visible and in some cases the measles
virus reaches the brain and causes a
brain infection if it does so the
chances of dying are between 20 to 40
percent and there may be long-term
damage but your body is far from giving
up at this stage and it fights back
aggressively some dendritic cells
survive long enough to activate the anti
virus forces of the body plasma cells in
the lymph nodes start producing billions
of antibodies tiny proteins that mark
infected cells for destruction or clump
the virus together killer T cells flood
the body and killin
it sells left and right after two to
three weeks the body usually gets the
upper hand and overwhelms the infection
but the immune system is now seriously
weakened and may take weeks or months to
recover leaving the body vulnerable to
other diseases but if you make it you
are now immune the immune system
remembers the virus forever measles is
no joke
although 84% of all humans are
vaccinated against measles one hundred
and twenty-two thousand people died
because of the infection in 2014 some
people cannot get vaccinations and
because they are too young because of
chemotherapy or HIV or because they're
allergic to the vaccine they need the
rest of us to stop the disease for them
the measles vaccination is safe cheap
and available there are no benefits from
having measles at all
you don't strengthen your immune system
and it's not more natural most people
who don't vaccinate only want the best
for their children
which is honorable but if you ask
yourself am i putting the life of my
child and other children at risk by not
vaccinating against measles the sad
answer is yes yes you are let's not play
the blame game though let's work
together and eradicate this virus
together we can get rid of these
dreadful monsters and consign them to
their rightful place the history books
[Music]
you